Selena Gomez and Zayn Malik sparking
romance rumors
[Music]
after they were spotted kissing in the
Big Apple while out on a dinner date
an eyewitness tellsy T Selena and Zayn's
romantic moment went down at a
restaurant in New York's Soho
neighborhood Lane Thursday night quote
they walked in holding hands and were
kissing
it seemed like they were comfortable
together and it was clear that it was a
date as you can see Zayn only follows 18
people
Selena being one of them that Tick Tock
tipped off the internet to the link up
the Creator sharing texts from a friend
who apparently works at Selena and
Zayn's date night spot you heard it here
first Selena's no stranger to dating
musicians she's previously been with the
weekend Nick Jonas and most famously
Justin Bieber what do you mean and just
last month the actress was linked to The
Chainsmokers Drew Taggart
a source telling ET at the time that
they were having a lot of fun together
and connected over their love of music
but not long after cell cleared up her
relationship status on Instagram hashtag
I am single I hate it when girls are
like oh my gosh my crush doesn't even
know that I exist like girl my crush
doesn't even exist
poking fun at her single single girls
status revealing that when it comes to a
special someone she's still out here
looking for him so could it be Zayn I
can't tell you time will tell he's also
used to high-profile romance after being
engaged to Little mix's Perrie Edwards
and later dating Gigi Hadid for years
the two share a two-year-old daughter
Kai the gentleman Advertiser full
details
[Music]
thank you